[Música]
los bancos centrales se esfuerzan por
desacelerar la inflación con medidas
como la subida de tasas de interés para
desincentivar el consumo ante estas
acciones algunas entidades bancarias han
iniciado lo que podría llamarse una
guerra de tasas bajando sus intereses y
en parte perjudicando la política
monetaria un ejemplo de ello se vive en
Colombia para analizar este caso nos
acompaña Alejandro chafuéne quien es
analista experto en economía
internacional y director gerente en
International action institute Muchas
gracias Alejandro por estar con nosotros
en directo América
el placer es mío
bueno optania la tiene la palabra si
gusta sí Alejandro
el caso de Colombia es muy particular
porque personalmente no he visto y usted
nos dirá si hay otros países de la
región que estén yendo en contra vía de
los bancos centrales estén diciendo
Bueno ya las tasas están muy altas es
hora de comenzar a bajarlas para que la
gente pues siga consumiendo
bueno el cada país es distinto así que
no se le puede echar la culpa a Estados
Unidos de la inflación en otros países y
del contagio en tasas de interés en
Suiza por ejemplo la tasa de inflación
es la mitad que en el resto de Europa en
Latinoamérica tenemos países como
Bolivia Ecuador El Salvador o Paraguay
países con distintas políticas monetaria
estructura monetaria pero que una
inflación mucho más baja y con tasa de
interés mucho más bajas que las de por
ejemplo Argentina al país donde nací Así
que hay cada uno de estos países está
respondiendo a la situación política
interna actual pero los economistas
sabemos que
los costos hay que pagar los Estados
Unidos gastó muchísima plata comienzos
desde comienzo de este siglo
eventualmente esto llegó a un momento
que no podía continuar y la tasa de
interés tenía que subir así que me
parece que es positivo que aumente la
tasa de interés me parece peligroso lo
que está haciendo
Colombia porque tiene el peligro de
terminar como como Argentina y tener
tasa de inflación que destruyen El poder
adquisitivo del pueblo
Alejandro hablando precisamente del caso
particular de Colombia la morosidad en
los créditos ha venido en aumento desde
el último año y aquí yo le pregunto es
preferible por ejemplo para para que con
los usuarios de hipoteca Pues aumenten
los pagos y bajen los intereses o
disminuir disminuir la cartera en deuda
no vale la pena digamos en este caso
pese a la política monetaria
esto es un balance que tiene que hacer
la la autoridad local y depende de cuán
extendido y esté ese problema de la Mora
en todo el sector bancario el sector de
poticas de Colombia así que el tema es
que si tiene que haber una especie de
salvataje que no sea un salvaje a los
dueños del banco tiene una especie de
ayuda a los ahorristas pero jugar con
medidas Macro como bajar la tasa de
interés muy por debajo de la inflación
eso básicamente lleva a al pasarle el
problema al futuro y eventualmente estos
costos se pagan Y hoy yo creo en Estados
Unidos se hicieron pagarlos ahora para
no tener que pagar estos costos el año
que viene que es un año de elección
presidencial y entraron a elección
presidencial con inflación y recesión es
algo muy peligroso para el el partido
que está gobernando
Alejandro Qué puede decirle a uno qué
puede decirle a usted como economistad a
los ciudadanos que ven como una tasa de
interés el día anterior en tarjeta de
crédito era del 46% anual y se la bajan
al 20% anual qué recomendaciones se le
podría dar a la gente también para que
esto no sea tampoco un incentivo para
que se endeuden y después no tengan con
que pagar
bueno es el tema de Educación económicas
esencial en todos los pueblos algunos de
nosotros pensamos que se había aprendido
de la elección del peligro de la
inflación Obviamente que el el que está
endeudado y de golpe de que ahora tiene
que pagar menos por las deudas lo ve
como un regalo pero de vuelta
es peligrosísimo endeudarse más allá de
los medios no solo para el país sino
para cada uno de los de los individuos
que toma prestado y que es partícipe en
el mercado lo que estamos viviendo El
problema es que la inflación y le envía
monetarias como una droga como la cola
al comienzo todo el mundo está le parece
bien Ahora podemos seguir gastando más
de lo que tenemos pero en el momento que
esto se para hay costos inevitables que
se tienen que pagar Pero nuevamente la
culpa la tienen más los políticos
irresponsables y la falta de Educación
económica de gente que vota
que toman medidas populistas y en vez de
gastar la plata que tienen tratan de
ponerle todo el peso en el pueblo que no
se da cuenta que la inflación es un
impuesto oculto que pagan que pagan
ellos y ese consejo de toda la vida de
pues para los usuarios mantener ahorros
no y no gastar de más que siempre será
útil Alejandro Quiero preguntarle pues
basados en todo lo que usted nos cuenta
cómo afectará esta guerra de tasas el
precio de los productos y de los
servicios
bueno de todo va a depender de si
continúa esta suba de la tasa de interés
acuérdense que la última vez que tuvimos
una fuerte tasa de interés en Estados
Unidos grande fue cuando al fin de la
época de carter al comienzo del
presidente Reagan se subieron las tasas
de interés más allá de la inflación la
inflación hoy es tres veces más alta es
que cuando asumió el presidente bailen
estamos alrededor del seis por ciento no
seis punto dos Comparado con dos punto
tres
para
si se sigue subiendo la tasa de interés
es probable que se frene la inflación y
que no sigan aumentando los precios en
Estados Unidos qué va a pasar en cada
país todo va a depender de la política
monetaria interna sobre todo en los
países que tiene moneda no atada al
Dólar Lamentablemente muchos países de
latinoamérica especialmente el caso de
Argentina Venezuela hay una mucha
responsabilidad fiscal y y ahí los
precios seguirán subiendo parece sin fin
así que todo dependerá de que cómo se
comporta la economía y cómo se balancee
no en estas cuerdas floja entre subir la
tasa de interés mucho y no destruir la
economía o no o bajarla y alimentarla la
la inflación para mí nuevamente
inflación es mentirse viendo que es mi
anti robar sabiendo que se robe el que
paga gastos fabricando billetes a mi
juicio está robándole al pueblo no y y
hay que tener mucho más cuidado con la
política monetaria de lo que se ha
tenido en estas últimas dos décadas al
principio cada país tiene de un cada uno
su propio caso y es distinto en Estados
Unidos ven como han subido tasas y la
inflación ha venido bajando pero si uno
ve a otros países como Colombia la
inflación viene subiendo al mismo ritmo
que viene subiendo las tasas de interés
entonces también es Es que otras
herramientas pueden tener las
de no solamente en decisiones de
política monetaria sino los gobiernos
también para poder bajar esos precios y
No necesariamente encareciendo el
crédito
buenísima buenísima tu pregunta tienes
que trabajar también por la oferta no
poner trabas a la importación permitir
que haya menos que haya menos
regulaciones para la gente puede entrar
al mercado aumentar el lado de la oferta
no porque qué quiere la inflación viene
cuando hay mucho más demanda que oferta
y consolidar esas demandas por emitir
dinero nuevamente no es solo la tasa de
interés Estados Unidos ha venido
reduciendo el incremento de la emisión
monetaria desde comienzo de año y de
fines de año pasado así que parte de la
baja de inflación se debe a eso así que
pero mi recomendación trabajen por el
lado de la oferta hagan más fácil a la
gente producir más
por más que parezca parado bajen
impuestos y van a terminar recaudando
más así que esa es mi recomendación
liberan más la economía integrense más
al mundo y y pídanle el pueblo Y ustedes
en los medios más responsabilidad fiscal
a los gobiernos
Alejandro rápidamente Entonces qué
podemos esperar en en la región créditos
más altos de ahora en adelante o ya
podemos esperar una estabilidad
rápidamente
parezco un disco repetido va a depender
de cada país a países como México están
muy atados a Estados Unidos yo creo que
va a seguir siendo desparejo y como tú
bien has dicho si hay Si los precios
siguen subiendo la tasa de interés va a
tener que subir al menos que uno quiera
caer como Argentina y Venezuela en una
hiperinflación así que espero que no le
pase a Colombia el resto de los países
de latinoamérica pues es Alejandro
chaufa en analista experto en economía
internacional es directora además
gerente en International acton institute
Gracias a ustedes por sus apreciaciones
y su análisis
gracias a ustedes el agradecimiento
también para usted Daniela y para
nuestros televidentes sigan en directo
América y ya volvemos con los titulares
[Música]